après cargo
c'était impossible pour moi d'imaginer
une suite à cargo
j'accueille axel Bauer
[Musique]
j'en ai marre
la détresse
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
axel Bauer dans le 9e arrondissement de
Paris l'auteur de Cargo de Nuit vit près
des lieux mythiques du rock français
[Musique]
il y a le Bus Palladium même le Lympia
il a été déplacé de quelques mètres
c'est plus l'Olympia
[Musique]
vous rendez compte on appelle ça la
campagne à Paris parce qu'il y a un
arbre qu'on voit dans la rue quand même
mais c'est pour nous parisiens ça fait
quand même la campagne
[Musique]
je les garde à la campagne de se marrer
[Applaudissements]
un magasin de guitare aux allures de
musée ça c'est vieille guitare en fait
elles ont toutes une histoire
on a qui date des années 40-50
[Musique]
voilà je crois que c'est ça voilà
c'est beau ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est une guitare je crois des années 70
ouais ouais mais c'est oui ça
a de la gueule comme on dit ça se
scarabée
un scarabée désaccordé mais un scarabée
quand même et
voilà elle est belle guitare ici
encore des gens qui veulent jouer de la
guitare
à bientôt salut
[Applaudissements]
le chanteur a maintenant rendez-vous
avec l'écrivain Gilles lotte on lui doit
la biographie de Johnny Hallyday avec
lui Axel coécrit la sienne
[Musique]
par
ton site d'écriture qui grandit non ça
m'a surpris
il y a une vraie énergie énorme quoi
c'est que des histoires très
rock'n'rolls et qui sont aussi
spirituels on est un peu pareil tous les
deux en fait on est issus du du rock n'
roll des années 70
lui il est plus Johnny Hallyday moi je
suis plus Léo c'est marrant parce que
j'en ai parlé à Johnny hier soir je suis
allé le voir dans le salage ça avait
meilleur des meilleurs gratteux de
l'Hexagone [ __ ] de de quoi ouais je
sais que axel Bauer c'est un grand
guitariste mais c'est quand même moi que
la voix la plus rock au monde de la
terre
au revoir Gilles
Axel rejoint à présent son ingénieur du
son
[Musique]
ensemble ils écoutent les premières
maquettes du prochain album d'Axel
s'il te plaît
ça me plaît beaucoup
c'est vrai qu'avant vous voyez des
consoles avec plein de boutons etc
maintenant on regarde la télé et puis
on s'amuse et on s'amuse on s'amuse
aussi
[Musique]
près de 30 ans après cargo souhaitons à
Axel Bauer qu'il retrouve le même succès
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière sera allume sur
axel Bauer bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout mon appareil alors Axel vous êtes
né à Paris le 7 avril 1961 enfance
musicale dans une famille musicienne
votre grand-père tenait l'harmonium à
l'église votre grand-mère jouait du
piano votre tante est une concertiste
classique de renommée internationale qui
interprétait Erik Satie Carnegie Hall
dans votre père Franck Bauer batteur de
jazz amateur c'est lui qui avait
organisé le premier festival de Jazz à
Paris après la guerre avec Miles Davis
Charlie Parker
Oscar Peterson et son pote Django
Reinhardt
et votre premier et moi musical c'est à
l'âge de 4 ans votre père avait ramené à
la maison
Oscar Peterson vous êtes assis sur ses
genoux quand il joue sur le piano
familial et là vous sentez les
vibrations de la musique qui traversent
son corps c'était une expérience de se
retrouver sur les genoux de ce gros
bonhomme comme ça qu'il jouait sur le
piano familial et qui me suit dessus à
goutte d'eau et et quiconque connaît
Oscar Peterson en train de jouer c'est
qui qui
fait des sons en même temps de jouer
comme ça je sentais dans sa poitrine le
le son du blues en fait il m'a il m'a
communiqué quelque chose de de sa
passion en fait de la musique votre père
c'est un sacré bonhomme conscient très
tôt du danger nazi il quitte la France
en 1940 pour rejoindre de Gaulle à
Londres et après quelques missions il
est engagé à la BBC et c'est le premier
à dire ici Londres les Français parlent
aux Français oui avec Pierre Dac Jean
berlé
les missions de la BBC et en juin 2010 à
Londres vous étiez avec votre père
invité par Nicolas Sarkozy pour la
commémoration de l'Appel du 18 juin oui
c'est vrai alors vos parents vous
mettent au piano à l'âge de 6 ans vous
préférez la batterie mais il y a des
voisins donc c'est un peu compliqué de
jouer de la batterie et à 12 ans vous
tombez dingue de la guitare lors d'un
concert des houx mon père qui c'est lui
qui m'a initié même à la musique rock en
fait je sais même pas comment il avait
entendu parler des où parce que mais il
est arrivé avec un jour dans ma chambre
avec deux tickets pour les où et on
s'est retrouvé
on s'est retrouvé tous les deux mon père
était plus vieux il avait 50 ans et on
était au milieu du dehors de hippie
comme ça qui nous poussaient parce que
c'est le le truc c'était de rentrer
gratos quoi donc on s'est retrouvé
acculé contre un mule un mur comme ça et
finalement on est rentré et on a vu les
où et c'était une révélation pour moi
alors votre père vous en fait donc amené
voir les où et quand il quitte la maison
la musique reste votre lien affectif à
tous les deux quoi mon père il est d'une
autre époque il est il m'a eu à 42 ans
donc il est vraiment de l'ancienne
génération où il est il est aussi de la
génération où les enfants parlaient pas
à table les enfants étaient des choses
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans et commencer à
voir un peu une sorte d'intelligence qui
vont commencer à poindre mais par contre
on avait effectivement ce lien par
rapport à la musique alors quand vos
parents se séparent vous êtes envoyés en
pension chez les curés à Pontoise à
Saint-Martin-de-France
là c'est une rupture affective totale
évidemment pour vous et vous dites la
guitare a été l'instrument de ma survie
directement dès que je suis arrivé
là-bas j'ai demandé à ma mère de
m'acheter une guitare elle m'a jeter un
truc
injouable avec les cordes à ça du manche
et
le soir dans le dortoir je me mettais
sous la couverture et j'apprenais la
guitare j'ai un magnétophone à cassette
avec les avec Johny Winter et j'essaie
de relever la guitare les solos et un
prof de trompette qui m'a appris à
l'accorder c'était le seul moyen pour
moi de supporter ça ouais de supporter
ça très mauvais souvenir là-bas même des
tentatives de viol
l'homosexualité était très présent dans
la pension donc je me suis inscrit à
l'atelier photo et donc on a été prendre
quelques photos avec deux trois gars ils
ont ils ont éteint la lumière et je me
suis retrouvé au sol
plaqué au sol par les gars il y en avait
un qui faisait des pompes en se frottant
la [ __ ] contre moi et donc ça a été fini
la photo je lui ai foutu un pain et je
suis sorti alors la première fois que
vous retrouvez sur scène c'est la fête
de l'école avec votre groupe les Nice
Bird et vous reprenez des morceaux des
studies d'acide ici mais en fait vous
avez tellement bu pour chasser le trac
vous souvenez plus du tout de cette
première performance on devait avoir 16
ans et j'avais pas vraiment bu beaucoup
de whisky dans ma vie et juste après la
balance on était dans un
bar pour attendre l'heure du concert et
il y en a un qui a dit un whisky puis
l'autre elle dit ouais bah ouais allez à
whisky et ce qui fait quand même on est
rentré sur scène complètement
ivre mort moi je crois que j'ai joué dos
au public je enfin je voyais plus rien
et les tous les mots mettaient c'est la
grande période des Verts c'est avec
Rocheteau et tout ça et tous les mots
m'allais retourner leur chaise vers le
fond et il gueulaient allez les verts
allez les verts alors à la fin des
années 70 je veux décrocher votre bac
vous inscrivez à une école préparatoire
pour les Beaux-Arts mais surtout vous
achetez votre première vraie guitare une
Gibson let's Paul que vous échangerez
contre une vieille Stratocaster c'est
réel à Dakar qu'est-ce que vous foutiez
à Dakar
j'ai suivi ma mère qui allait elle
travaille pour l'hôtel Méridien il y
avait un méridien à Dakar donc et là
effectivement il y avait un groupe qui
jouait dans l'hôtel et le guitariste du
groupe a dit elle est pas mal ta guitare
moi je voyais qu'il tirait des bons
sondes sa guitare on a joué un peu
ensemble et à la fin on s'est échangé
carrément le le nos guitare il m'a filé
je savais pas que c'était une série elle
en plus d'une céréale c'est une guitare
qui qui vaut une fortune maintenant et
mais il me l'a filé dans des sacs en
plastique alors que moi effectivement je
faisais m'acheter une Gibson lespool
toute neuve et j'ai fait ce truc là on a
échangé j'ai flashé sur le son de cette
guitare alors à l'époque vous jouez
aussi en studio avec des petits groupes
vous écrivez des chansons et un jour
vous compilez quatre titres sur une
cassette pour faire le tour des maisons
de disque c'est votre morceau qui qui
intéresse et Philippe Missir de mondiaux
musique la belle distribué par Vogue
vous demande d'autres titres parmi
lesquels il y a les Bauches du couplet
de Cargo de Nuit je pense j'avais
j'avais un désir de signer mais ça a
pris tellement de temps en fait Philippe
me demandait toujours de revenir avec
des nouveaux titres puis un jour
effectivement je lui amener le couplet
de cargo et là il m'a dit bon je vais
faire écouter à mon partenaire Michel
Eli voilà alors Michel Eli il écrit les
paroles et vous envoie un studio tout de
suite quoi oui on s'est retrouvé en fait
il y a pas mal de gens qui ont travaillé
sur le texte de cargo et c'est trop un
texte puis rien de nous satisfait et à
la je crois que c'était le 14 juillet
on est parti chacun de notre côté avec
un papier à crayon et et le texte de
Michel était était vraiment bien et
c'était le texte de cargo voilà et
on l'a enregistré direct alors malgré
l'insistance de Vogue vous refusez de
raccourcir le morceau qui faisait 4-45
parce qu'à l'époque c'est tout le temps
3 minutes vous êtes nul bon faut dire
que Radio 7 énergie on jouait le jeu
c'est le début des radios libres
ils ont besoin de morceaux comme ça
étendard qui font la différence avec on
va dire la vieille programmation de
variétés de l'époque et ça nous a
effectivement bien aidé mais c'est
surtout le public je vais te dire qu'il
nous a bien aidé parce que le premier
passage de cargo qui était sur Radio 7
je crois qu'il y a eu 500 personnes qui
ont appelé pour demander qu'est-ce que
c'était à la suite de mon Dino
c'est le premier clip français programmé
sur MTV c'était un peu une galère de
faire un clip au début parce que
l'éclipse ça n'existait pas en fait donc
on a été voir Léon cabas au départ qui
était le patron de Vogue on lui a
expliqué qu'on voulait faire un truc
nous a regardé vont arrêter déjà disque
d'or alors
il nous a écouté il a dit combien
moi il a filé un peu de thune pour qu'on
fasse le truc ensuite il y avait l'autre
tête qui était un truc du ministère de
la Culture et là on faisait des petits
déjeuners très très bon le les matins
ils nous demandait un storyboard mais
mon Dino c'est pas de storyboard et en
fait chaque petit déjeuner ce terminé
invariablement par
le mec tête me disant est-ce que tu
viens ce soir à la piscine parce qu'ils
étaient tous au mot et finalement on a
on a bien compris que si j'y passais pas
à la casserole
bah il y aurait pas de d'argent de
l'hôtel donc on a fonctionné sans eux on
est parti là vous devenez célèbre quels
ont été les réactions de votre entourage
devant votre célébrité mes copains sont
séparés de moi
parce que j'avais trop de succès avec
les filles
qu'on se retrouver à table comme ça avec
des avec des filles et
le même si je me mettais en retrait dès
que je disais tu peux me passer le sel
il y avait trois mains des nanas qui se
tendaient et donc donc les autres
étaient écoeurés ils disaient on peut
pas lutter
c'est une période fantastique mais en
même temps voilà on se retrouve de plus
en plus isolé et on se rapproche des
gens qui vivent la même chose que nous
et votre maman comment la réagit
bien elle était fière et votre père
ouais lui il m'emmenait à la
photocopieuse pour faire un autographe
pour avoir des réducs avec
[Rires]
les médias ça c'est bien passé non
je crois oui
j'ai gagné un peu d'argent avec cargo à
ce moment-là d'ailleurs énormément en
fait ça me paraît énorme
et puis
et puis j'ai commencé un album et Léon
cabas a mis en faillite et
et puis m'a redemandé la somme que
j'avais gagnée finalement pour garder
mes bandes mon premier album tu vois
donc finalement j'ai pas gagné lourd à
ce moment là à la sortie cargo c'est une
opération blanche pour vous pratiquement
pratiquement pratiquement l'amour on en
parle pas donc vous aviez un succès
phénoménal oui mais c'était pas de
l'amour
vous avez profité oui surtout que
j'étais
plutôt très timide donc là c'est quand
même une situation vachement bien on n'a
pas trop à faire le premier pas
et donc oui il fallait que je fasse un
peu mon éducation sexuelle aussi
quel était le meilleur moment de toute
cette époque cargo je crois que tout du
long parce que c'était une découverte
permanente il y a des épisodes il y a
des anecdotes mais d'abord on a été très
soudé avec Michel Élie Philippe Missir
Jean-Baptiste mondinot
il y a eu des belles rencontres coacher
qui était dj-les-bains
etc que tu as un pote j'ai rencontré
plein de gens intéressants aussi donc
Mick Jagger que je rencontre un soir et
qui me dit j'adore ton truc
et peut-être le plus le pic du truc ça a
été cette émission de télé ou
j'entends dans ma loge un anglais qui
râle parce qu'on lui a perdu sa guitare
et et j'en ai marre de l'entendre et je
prends justement ma strate
et je sors dans le couloir et je lui
colle la guitare comme ça dans les bras
et je lui dis vas-y mec nous fait pas
chier faites ton truc avec celle-là et
génial et là je lève je lève les yeux et
c'est Roger daltreet
est où ça renvoie à 74 à 74 pourquoi je
fais de la musique et tout d'un coup le
gars regarde la guitare et il me dit yes
fort tu vois et on commence à discuter
et comme il devait me rendre la guitare
ben il a regardé
ma prestation avec cargo salut à plus et
deux semaines après il appelait mon
manager et pour reprendre la chanson
donc
commencez par être un môme qui va au
concert des ou qui se dit [ __ ] c'est
génial oui one getful de gain quand même
les mecs étaient là on y croyait où ils
vont en get full again on se fera plus
jamais baiser la gueule quoi
et là moins de 10 ans après je rencontre
d'altret et il reprend ma chanson j'ai
pas beaucoup plus beau cadeau top
meilleur moment alors cargo se vend à
700 000 exemplaires mais
bon pas le dire comme ça mais il paraît
que les usines tournaient la nuit
d'accord et donc le vrai chiffre serait
un million 800000 ensuite fantasme
200.000 avant Jessy 60000 évidemment
difficile de refaire un succès comme
comme cargo la maison de Nice fait
faillite et là le rêve voilà le rêve est
un peu terminé
non j'étais pas inquiet tout ça avait
été très vite c'était
très surprenant le problème si vous avez
été catalogué dans ce personnage un peu
querelle Fassbender le marin en cuir etc
lui ce titre à conditionner ma vie après
cargo
c'était impossible de pour moi enfin
d'imaginer une suite à cargo voilà et à
ce moment-là les gens attendaient une
suite à cargo pas de beau jour ou radeau
du soir
mais
quoi que je fasse derrière je pense ça
n'aurait pas marché d'ailleurs j'ai dû
attendre 10 ans avant que
d'excellents morceaux par la suite
effectivement éteint la lumière est un
morceau formidable vraiment excellent ça
vous ramène d'ailleurs sous les feux de
la rampe à ce moment-là à ma place avec
Zazie très mal accueilli parce que
formaté bizarrement quoi au début c'est
vrai que
on n'a pas été très soutenu dès le début
par les radios ensuite ça a suivi mais
comme tous les trucs que j'ai fait
éteint la lumière la maison disent
voulait pas le sortir
cargophone 2002 au NRJ Music Awards et
maintenant c'est devenu un classique
mais c'est vrai qu'on s'est sorti
c'était compliqué voilà c'est le public
qui l'a porté en fait oui tous les trucs
que j'ai fait c'est toujours le public
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique
de l'époque cargo
non non c'est comme une expérience un
apprentissage mais non non je suis pas
d'ailleurs je vis pas dans le passé donc
vous avez de la rancune contre des gens
si je vais être parfaitement honnête
Leon cabas dont je parlais tout à
l'heure de Vogue
j'étais pas génial ce qu'il a fait quand
même il s'est pas super bien comporté
non et vous a repris le pognon de cargo
et après il a fait tourner
et en plus il croyait pas donc
c'est pas la classe si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil Axel moi je suis un intuitif donc
j'avance comme ça
j'avance avec ce que je sens et en me
retournant en arrière je comprends
pourquoi ma vie a été comme ça et
pourquoi elle est un peu en dentie et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé etc donc je
chaque chacune de ces choses m'a amené à
être ce que je suis aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui je me sens mieux que
rien qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
marque sur votre tombe quand vous allez
mourir si j'ai un lion de gouttière
c'est très bien je suis très heureux de
rallumer la lumière soit vous merci
Thierry et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu